[Musique]
et bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour ce deuxième
numéro du club de la presse sur tv 78 de
la chaîne v zibeline émission aussi
retransmise sur l fm radio 95.5 autour
de cette table acquis mahaya bonjour
vous êtes la rédactrice en chef de l fm
à vos côtés elle lahbib eddaouidi
bonjour bonjour hu directeur des
gazettes gazette en yvelines gazette de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également face
à vous bernard delattre bon vieux renard
ancien journaliste à toutes les
nouvelles dans les yvelines pendant une
bonne vingtaine d'années
et puis aujourd'hui 40 ans je m'oublie
la moitié est également écrivain
aujourd'hui et puis engager sur le plan
associatif est à vos côtés grégory canal
et bonjour grégory joseph rédacteur en
chef adjoint de tv 78 au sommaire de ce
club de la presse mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites le premier
ministre a dévoilé les grandes lignes du
projet du gouvernement la colère ne
cesse pas pour autant elle s'exprime
aussi dans les yvelines
autre sujet qui a fait l'actualité en ce
mois de décembre le est démantèlement
dans le camp de réfugiés tibétains hr
plus de 700 personnes logées dans de
nombreuses villes du département
politique avec une tendance claire pour
les municipales qui approche la
multiplication des listes dites sans
étiquette à gauche comme à droite la
mode n'est définitivement plus au parti
nous parlerons aussi des faits que news
elle s'immisce jusque dans l'actualité
dans la presse régionale et puis nous
verrons quelles sont les personnalités
du mois dans le département à l'honneur
notamment le cas piscine jeunes
ventriloque et gérard larcher président
du sénat
nous sommes le 20 à décembre et nous
débutons avec l'actualité du mois
la réforme des retraites inscrite dans
le projet présidentiel d'emmanuel
maquereau en 2010 est engagée
véritablement avec un cycle de
consultations en 2018 elle ces contrées
de concrétiser pardon avec la
présentation d'un projet ce mois ci dans
les grandes lignes
l'institution d'un régime de retraite
universel en plaçant les quarante deux
systèmes existants mise en relation
directe du montant de la retraite avec
les cotisations elle versé c'est le
fameux système à points ou encore la
mise en place de mesures pour améliorer
les retraites des plus défavorisés
seulement le projet est loin de faire
l'unanimité auprès des syndicats
mouvements de grève depuis le 5 décembre
plusieurs manifestations sur fond
également de grogne sociale plus
généralisée avec des manifestations donc
sur paris et puis aussi dans les
yvelines à travers toute la france on va
d'abord faire un état des lieux sur le
département dans le nord du département
peut être un climat concrètement il ya
une démobilisation des manifestations on
sait qu'un avis sur versailles il y en a
eu aussi sur le nord du département
absolument et du côté de du secteur du
mantois avec plusieurs manifestations
notamment de l'assemblée de l'udc du
mantois avec la participation des
différents syndicats
l'ensemble des syndicats soulignaient le
fait qu'ils avaient une espèce de
convergence et qu'il était rare que ces
syndicats se trouve côte à côte réunis
pour contre plutôt là cette réforme de
la retraite ce qu'on a pu constater
aussi c'est que l'opinion était aussi
prisonnière de sa en dépit d'un taux
plutôt favorable au niveau national et à
52% selon le le sondage ifop
donc oui une forte mobilisation aussi
sur notre secteur mais je suis un
ralentissement aussi oui de la vie
économique
je vois faire un parallèle tout de même
parce que bernard delattre vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure justement vous
êtes journaliste depuis plus de 40 ans
maintenant les grèves de 95
vous les avez forcément forcément
couverte aussi on peut faire un
parallèle avec 1995 sur la mobilisation
will mais le contexte différent sur le
sol le contexte est totalement différent
là on est vraiment dans un code figure
différents et c'est pas simple moi j'ai
des dans le vie associative hier j'étais
avec une dame qui est pour la grève même
si elles embêté parce qu'elle va perdre
de l'argent avec le nouveau système de
retraite on comprend qu'elle se batte et
d'un autre côté dans une autre
association j'ai un copain qui devait
partir à noël dans le sud-ouest pour sa
fille est en train il avait acheté le
ticket de tram puis on ya le train est
supprimé
donc on lui rembourse son ticket de tram
et il doit prendre sa voiture et puis
d'un peu handicapé dont qui l'embêté
quoi même avec un parallèle à une
dualité entre c'est cette volonté de
soutenir la grève et ce depuis le
quotidien des gens vous avez pu
constater si on peut voir pour ceux qui
nous suivent sur tv 78 quelques images
dont c'était en 1995 la manifestation à
l'époque sur sur le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines contestation contre
la réforme des retraites aussi à
l'époque mais pas seulement alain juppé
premier ministre avait aussi prévu une
réforme de la sécurité sociale
plusieurs mesures difficiles sur le plan
économique pour équilibrer les comptes
de l'état est là pour ces quelques
images d'archivés si vous me suivez sur
tv 78 grégory justement sur tv 78 de ces
mobilisations vous l'avez suivi vous
avez reçu plusieurs syndicats la grogne
aujourd'hui bien installée elle est bien
installé comme le disait hakima on avait
reçu les syndicats donc unis
il y avait la cgt solidaires fsu et
également fo qui était venu sur notre
plateau pour parler une construction
commune d'un plan de lutte contre contre
cette réforme des retraites
nous on a constaté en tout cas sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
versailles et le sud yvelines une forte
mobilisation notamment sur les deux
premiers jours où il ya eu très peu de
trains des mobilisations également dans
les rues de versailles et une
mobilisation qui a été assurée au niveau
local notamment par la cgt cheminots de
versailles qui a fait des actions
vraiment tous les jours des blocages
notamment des blocages de dépôts de bus
le dépôt ski bus qui dessert
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise le
dépôt fébus qui est sur l'agglomération
versailles grand parc et a aussi à noter
qu'il ya une coupure d'électricité qui a
été opéré dès la deuxième semaine
deuxième semaine de cette grève
une coupure d'électricité qui a touché
notamment l'hôtel de police de
versailles la préfecture et mais aussi
des commerçants on a eu plusieurs
restaurateurs au téléphone qui nous ont
fait part le soir même voilà ils n'ont
pas pu assurer une n'ont pas pu assurer
leur service et donc une perte une perte
de chiffre d'affaires sur ce soit sur le
plan économique
quel regard peut-être la bible vous vous
portez directeur des gazettes sur les
yvelines plan économique un seul point
et quand même je pense que c'est un peu
tôt pour tirer deux leçons bien précises
ou avoir une vue plus objectif mais une
chose certaine c'est que c'est
indéniable que c'est une réussite
l'une de manifestations dont nous avons
est que cette cette grève qui dure et
qui malgré
ce que les médias nationaux je suis
frappé par la manière non l'objectif
d'un certain nombre de médias nationaux
qui prennent position ce matin
j'écoutais encore une radio et on
parlait du coupures de courant dans le
sud dans lequel il y avait une crèche
qui avait été fortement handicapé une
maison de retraite etc
mais la réalité c'est que c'est les
manifestants et ceux qui ont coupé la
greffe ne ciblait pas la crèche ne
ciblait pas c'est une incidence
néanmoins mais le message qui force et
c'est ce qui est ciblé en l'occurrence
dans cette zone là ce sont les services
de l'état c'est l'économie et faire
passer à la population aux auditeurs
qu'en réalité ce qui ont été
essentiellement touché ce sont que des
structures
c'est vrai que ça fait pleurer dans les
chaumières c'est vrai qu'au quelque part
ce média prend position contre la grève
est donc contre les grévistes et que
donc contre le mouvement social et c'est
là ou bien il ya un vrai prendre toute
la presse locale en l'occurrence dont
nous faisons partie un certain nombre
d'entre nous ici font un super job et
c'est pas le cas rien mais c'est vrai
parce qu'aucune émission vous l'avez ses
prix d'honneur ces très grandes villes
escales très objectif
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui c'est le
cas aujourd'hui de ces médias son
service de multinationales qui ont pris
position et qui décide de retourner une
partie de la population voire l'ensemble
de la population contre la grève
je trouve que c'est pas très pro et
c'est pas trés d'anthologie néanmoins il
faut bien est ce qu'il faut en parler ou
pas d incidence que ça peut avoir sur
les créations vous devez traiter
l'information dans l' équilibre
vous avez effectivement le il faut le
dire qui a début des problèmes dans les
crèches des problèmes dans les méandres
d'un mais en parallèle expliqué aussi
que la cible des grévistes s'est pas
lassé de ces grévistes étaient peut-être
des services de l'état peut-être des
grandes usines peut-être un indé
peut-être et en l'occurrence sur cette
région là c'était plutôt amazon qui
était ciblé
donc voilà je trouve qu'il ya un
déséquilibre de l'information qui est
scandaleux la règle des journalistes
c'est vraiment des deux éclairages de
nouveaux éclairages sur le fait d'être
contradictoire croiser les infos
dans un certain nombre de médias
nationaux vraiment prenne position
vous dites que la presse de proximité et
plus proche des gens donc elle l est
moins manipulés jetons variateur d'un
mobilisation en main je n'ai jamais vu
une mobilisation aussi importante sur
une grève et amante ou à pau si je sors
versailles également depuis ces dix
dernières années mais jamais autant de
monde il use ex en un seul dans les rues
de versailles jeudi
c'est impressionnant je pense qu'il ya
très longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu pour un
mouvement social
une mobilisation aussi importante mais
plus que de nombreux comptes des
différentes mobilisations je pense aussi
que notre rôle en tant que média local
c'est donner de l'information pratique
effectivement il ya des perturbations
sur les transports dont le voit à la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines où
c'est la ligne n la ligne une le rer c
qui passe et c'est vrai que depuis
depuis le début du mouvement il ya très
peu de trains qui passent et c'est aussi
les usagers qui sont impactés donc nous
on est aussi là pour donner de
l'information pratique voilà équilibré
et aussi voilà donner donner ces
informations aux usagers on parle à tout
à l'heure de la fecq nous mais quelque
part ce mode d'information
c'est une information biaisée et wise as
très loin de là fait que nous
il faut rendre compte aussi des deux de
ceux qui sont actifs solidaire et de
ceux qui subissent la grève ou en tout
cas qui en comprennent pas forcément
tous les ans elle et les enjeux
effectivement je vous rejoins du côté
des usagers
on peut dire que la mobilité pas
nécessairement le point fort de
territoires fant surtout sur notre
secteur on peut dire qu'au bout de sept
jours
quoi qu'il en soit on peut dire
objectivement que cette grève a achevé
les usagers quand même une fatigue
accumulée
on peut le dire sans trop prendre parti
là dessus on a quoi redorer évidemment
il vous dans 7 à simplement vous avez
rencontré quelques usagers si on peut
peut-être les enfants oui absolument on
a cherché aussi à on s'est intéressés
aussi à ceux qui ne faisait pas grève
parce qu'il y en a quelques-uns et on
leur a posé tout simplement la question
pourquoi pourquoi vous ne fait pas grève
c'était à mantes la jolie
[Musique]
chaque jour chaque jour une question
d'actu causés aux auditeurs de
l'événement je suis enseignant moi je
vais être bien dérape à faire grève
demain mais je fais pas grève parce que
vous faites
je considère que l'idée de la retraite
mettre tout le monde sur un pied
d'égalité
c'est plutôt pas une mauvaise idée
appartement ou valorise les salaires
j'ai peu de logs si je travaille pas
j'ai pas d'argent qui rentre tout
simplement pas non en fait ensuite il
avancé
je fais un boulot plus importantes
approchent donc pas je m'occupe de
chauveau donc je peux pas je ne peux pas
faire grève
est-ce que vous pensez que l'opinion au
moment où va se retourner si pendant la
trêve des confiseurs il n'y a pas de
trêve justement en tout cas ce qu'on
entend ce qu'on a pu entendre sur ce
micro trottoir c'est on ne sait pas
grève mais beaucoup parce que on va
perdre de l'argent on ne peut pas se
permettre ce et c'est la raison
principale c'est oui je peux pas me
permettre
il faut que faut que je paye il faut
avoir les moyens de sa politique même
quand on est gréviste voilà on va faire
simple oui mais en même temps il y avait
quand même un fort soutien et puis les
non grévistes sont extrêmement solidaire
des grévistes
après on a une réforme qui est quand
même quitte une réforme très importante
mais rend le temps qu'ils qui part avec
un handicap très fort enfin elle est
très mal préparée le type qui la porte
est obligé de céder le principal
handicap cette émission c'est juste
inconcevable même qu'on puisse avoir un
ne pas suffisamment avoir enquêté de
part du secrétariat général de l'élysée
pour pouvoir le mettre à ce poste là et
puis ensuite moi j'écoutais encore hier
le secrétaire d'état qui l'a remplacé
qui nous expliquent qu'un logiciel qui
me mais en même temps il y pas fiable
permettez moi de vous dire que que on a
toutes les conditions dans ce dossier
pour que ça continue pour que ça dure et
pour surtout que le gouvernement recule
parce que l'opinion naturellement un
constate que c'est pas bien préparé que
le porteur n'est pas le bon que celui
qui suit ne maîtrise pas et que même les
logiciels que l'état a mis en place ne
sont pas fiables et c'est de la bouche
du secrétaire d'état hier soir que
j'écoutais dans un dé journal de 20
heures en tout cas du côté de la
rédaction de fm effectivement on n'a pas
rencontré lors des différents micros
trottoirs qu'on a pu faire d'hostilité
wilner vis-à-vis des visages est
seulement demandé
on va peut-être écouter un autre micro
trottoir qu'on a réalisé sur saint
quentin en yvelines ce qui était souvent
demandé c'est une petite pause voilà
juste le temps de faire la fête en
famille un petit peu mais mais mais
derrière il y avait plutôt un soutien on
écoute ce micro-trottoir justement
tourné à saint quentin en yvelines
tu vas à fond vu que je vais en cours il
bloque pas le pays
mais mais en soi ça me dérange pas de
plus est ce que j'ai la voiture est faux
que le présent répondre à ça plus ou
moins oui enfin d'un point de vue pour
mon futur oui mais actuellement ça m'a
beaucoup embêté pour revenir en cours
justement je soutiens la grève pourquoi
parce qu'il ya leurs efforts menés vous
ne nous convient pas donc oui je
souhaitais pas du tout pas du tout non
pas parce que les gens ne réfléchissent
pas hong kong a l'impression qu'ils
comprenaient en rien moi je suis
retraité donc je peux parler maintenant
je suis retraité mais j'ai l'impression
que ben
on n'a pas des finances on n'a pas les
moyens aujourd'hui 102 difficile sinon
après on va vers la retraite a commencé
hier un capitalisation
je ne le soutient plus changé parce que
la grève qu'il y a maintenant ça n'a
plus rien à voir avec
les déterminants initiaux des terminaux
initiaux manifestations contre cette
réforme des retraites et puis aussi
cette grogne sociale on va voir un
forcément vous allez suivre dans vos
différentes rédactions
là comment ça va ça va évoluer au cours
des prochaines semaines peut-être en
janvier encore d'aider forte
mobilisation nous verrons et vous serez
informé bien sûr dans vos différents
médias on passe au reste de l'actualité
les autres sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité en ce mois de décembre le
club de la presse qui se poursuit avec
acquis maria rédactrice en chef de lfm
bernard delattre ancien journaliste est
tout seul et nouvelle aujourd'hui
écrivain et puis engager sur le plan
associatif lahbib eddaouidi directeur
est des gazelles il ya 50 ans gaz est en
yvelines et puis grégory canal et
rédacteur en chef de tv 78 parlons à
présent des réfugiés dans le département
avec ce camp à achères de personnes
originaires du tibet un camps démantelés
et une population répartis aux quatre
coins du département des yvelines
reportage sur l'arrivée justement d'une
partie d'entre eux à villepreux ils sont
repartis depuis on va y revenir
l'arrivée c'était le 3 décembre sujet de
tv 78 leur bus les a déposés aux
alentours de 14 heures au gymnase alain
mimoun de villepreux ce mardi 3 décembre
91 réfugiés tibétains sont arrivés dans
la commune en provenance d'un campement
de fortune situé à achères un site
évacué par la préfecture un peu plus tôt
dans la matinée
maintenant je me sens mieux parce que
nous n'avions pas de maison la nuit
faisait vraiment très froid
on est très très très content on est
très satisfait on remercie vraiment
toutes les personnes qui ont contribué
bas
à la victoire en fait parce que c'est
une victoire quand même pour nous à leur
arrivée les réfugiés ont été accueillis
avec un thé chaud et des biscuits par
une vingtaine d'habitants de la commune
venus bénévolement un élan de solidarité
qui a commencé via un service de
messagerie instantanée dimanche dernier
beaucoup de villes provient se sont
mobilisés actuellement on est à peu près
70 qui on souhaitait donc venir en aide
sur la logistique les repas la
convivialité éventuellement les inviter
chez nous de temps en temps pendant la
durée de leur séjour dans la commune
certaines activités associatives de la
ville ont dû être déplacés sur d'autres
sites
la première des choses c'est qu'en tant
que maire on a une crainte très égoïste
on se dit mais comment je vais faire
pour que la ville continue de
fonctionner il ya une très forte
collaboration de l'ensemble des
associations qui étaient impactés tout
simplement pour se mettre en phase qui
va aller ou pas ce que c'est vrai qu'on
perd quand même une salle majeur donc il
fallait qu'on replace les associations
dans la ville les réfugiés devrait
rester jusqu'au 5 janvier dans la
commune ils seront de nouveau dépassé
dans une autre ville après cette date
grégory c'est arrivé à villepreux s'est
plutôt bien passé c'est ce que vous avez
pu constater s'est bien déroulé alors
contrairement à ce qui a été dit dans le
sujet c'est vrai que cet accueil était
prévue jusqu'au 5 janvier son parti
finalement le jeudi 12 décembre donc
environ 91 91 réfugiés un conte été
accueilli à lille pro ça s'est plutôt
bien déroulé
le maire de villepreux stéphane denis
rambaud le disais il ya une
réorganisation qui a été quand même
nécessaire des activités qui ont été
transférés dans d'autres structures de
la ville mais le téléthon par exemple a
pu être maintenue au complexe sportif
alain mimoun ait eu quelques ajustements
et surtout ce qu'on a pu constater sur
place c'est qu'il ya une grande
solidarité en tout cas qui s'est mise en
place alors et via l'association à ces
aires qui a été chargé cet accueil des
réfugiés tibétains mais aussi d'autres
associations on a reçu en plateau
l'association mali les moon ou alors qui
est une association plaisir oise d'une
commune environnante mais qui très vite
dès cette information de l'accueil des
réfugiés tibétains à villepreux a voulu
mettre sa pierre à l'édifice et aider à
l'accueil des réfugiés et il en sera lui
le font aussi une collecte une collecte
de fonds qui a été opéré notamment
par le biais d'un stage un stage de kung
fu qui s'est déroulée dimanche dernier
sur la commune qui a été organisée par
l'association pro fight qui a organisé
ce stage en présence d'un maître kung fu
reconnu et qui voit la récolter des
fonds et ont reversé ces fonds à
l'association acr par contre le problème
de fond c'est l'accueil des réfugiés
parce que là ils sont ils étaient donc
sur hr d'ailleurs si vous nous suivez
sur la tv 78 les images derrière nous
sont celles du camp de hr depuis ils
sont partis ils ont même encore changer
de lieu ils sont repartis sur mantes la
ville les réfugiés de villepreux dans
d'autres structures
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus trop comment
les accueillir comment faire vous les
voyez partir sur vos territoires revenir
la bible peut être dans une chose de
certaine c'est qu'on peut pas laisser
des camps comme via des centaines de
personnes dans un état
du vin c'est un deal d'une république
c'est une manie malade quelques photos
on a du mal à croire qu'on se trouve en
france quand on voit les conditions
d'accueil et de quotidiens pour ces
réfugiés
il se trouve que j'ai été les voir et
c'est juste inadmissible
alors après c'est un peu faim après vous
avez commandé dispatchés entre
guillemets faut savoir que c'est la
préfecture de région qui décide c'est
pas la préfecture des yvelines
or les acteurs la préfecture des
yvelines a un regard plus plus juste sur
l'équilibrage d'envoyer certains ici
certains la préfecture de région a
tendance à dire bon on va les envoyer à
mantes la jolie où on va les envoyer à
trappes on va les envoyer aux mureaux ce
qu'il faut surtout pas faire
il faut plutôt que ce soit la préfecture
les zinic soit en charge et qui a
elle-même dispatch en fonction des
possibilités entre guillemets ça ne sert
à rien de rajouter de la misère à la
misère ça ne sert à rien d'en rajouter
des gens attrapent ça ne sert à rien de
rajouter des gens qui sont déjà en
difficulté à mantes la jolie
ça me fait un peu penser l'impôt
logements sociaux c'est que tout le
monde considère qu'il faut des logements
sociaux donc tout le monde est d'accord
que c'est une situation inacceptable et
personne n'en veut chez eux c'est
exactement pareil sérieusement sociaux
ont dit oui il faut des logements
sociaux parce que pour nos enfants etc
mais surtout pas à côté de chez nous et
c'est la même chose sur les réfugiés
en l'occurrence lassé des tibétains sur
une certaine guého tease à sion les on
les regroupe noms des noms désiste au
fond réquisitionner les hôtels aussi
qu'ils sont peu utilisées
c'est pas la première fois il est je
crois qu'il y avait un campement aussi
qui avait été démantelé à conflans
sainte honorine c'est une actualité qui
revient souvent aussi sur la table des
cris de paris aussi renvoyés dans les
yvelines tellement porte de la chapelle
et autres les réfugiés et les migrants
que l'on retrouve avez raison les airs
et c'est une actualité qui a besoin
régulièrement sur la table effectivement
on a reçu à plusieurs reprises la ligue
des droits de l'homme qui nous
expliquaient aussi la complexité du
processus et notamment pour avoir le
statut de demandeur de droit d'asile ça
mais environ 6 mois donc du coup
effectivement il ya ce ballottage des
réfugiés c'est toujours été une réalité
dans le département bernard delattre
j'ai une amie qui s'occupent d'un
réfugié et de cyril mais c'est très
compliqué ça fait trois ans qu'elle se
bat pendant les papiers c'est un
parcours du combattant faut passer un
temps fou il manque toujours une pièce
est elle fait de l'alphabétisation à la
mjc de rambouillet et la haye ce jeune
c'est vraiment il ya sa famille là bas
tous les parcs pour le projet des
tibétains je pense c'est le moment des
données aussi l'impérialisme de la chine
nana ou en 1950 a annexé le tibet
pourquoi parce que c'était le château
d'eau de tous les grands fleuves chinois
ils veulent reconstituer l empire et on
peut on peut parler presque de génocide
culturel vis-à-vis du peuple tibétain
ils avaient leur culture qui est ce
qu'il est mais carey spectale le deuil
il a été obligé de déminer au en had
c'est quand même scandaleux et oui ce
qui se passe à hong kong aussi des cas
veut imposer les hong kong étaient
habitués ancienne colonie britannique
est habitué à avoir un peu un système
occidental avec liberté dans
l'enseignement l'éducation et pékin veut
leur imposer son système et vous avez vu
comme ils se battent les gens ce qui
s'axe en train de perdre leur liberté
j'ai vu le régime de pics de pékin tout
le monde est photographié on vous suit
vous avez a permis à points vie à plus
de liberté quoi et c'est quand même
scandaleux que que le
la chine comme ça annexe le tibet hong
kong après savez de taiwan en fait on
était un peu le lin politique de la
chine
à cela vous pouvez rajouter 30 millions
de musulmans qui sont sans doute marqué
dans des campements qu'ils soient
considérés comme sous citoyens ainsi que
mandanda évidemment essentielle système
chinois évidemment écho au rayon
vainqueurs l'ensemble des dirigeants
chinois avec le tapis rouge
encore une fois une année de réfugiés de
2000 valeur de 10 20 ans il y avait
autant de migration vous l'avez constaté
dans le département c'était déjà une
réalité
cette attaque est la même un suspense
dure avec moi je pense qu'on avait moins
il ya toujours eu des mails est bon vous
avez vu les gens qui sont prêts à
risquer leur vie pour traverser la
méditerranée quand on sait que le smig
irak 50 euros cameroun qui a rien y'a
pas d'être social pas d'aidé médicale on
comprend que les gens voient là la
france est l'eldorado salom le
comparatif est pas forcément le bon
puisqu'on est sur deux mondes totalement
différents vins moyen-orient qui est
totalement exploser les
environnementalistes climatique on a le
le maghreb et le monde arabe qui est
complètement de la même manière explosé
depuis on va subir dans les années à
venir et encore plus la pression du
gratin des jeunes dont je vous parlais
en fait celle afghans il était menacé de
mort par l'italie bon tout ça quoi
voilà donc on comprend que risquent leur
vie pour venir mais ça mais par contre
pour venir sur les problématiques du
coup locales qui sont entraînés on peut
aussi évoqué un manque de communication
parfois de cette préfecture de région
parce que c'est très difficile de savoir
ce qui va advenir de ces migrants où ils
vont être installés même pour
communiquer pour nous pour informer sur
dans quelle situation ça va se faire
dans quel contexte comment ça se passe
quelles sont les structures
réquisitionnés c'est comme les
municipalités qui le découvrent le matin
même qu'il ya un quart de migrants qui
va venir l'arrivée s'installer chez eux
et on a le même problématique
l'accueil s'est passé bon gré mal gré le
départ sion de départ de ces fiches sur
le départ du maire front national et
donc d'extrême droite demandent sa vie
dont on a eu un communiqué de presse qui
nous informait qu'effectivement le
campement la chaire allait être
démantelé on savait qu'ils avaient dix
sites dans les yvelines qui étaient
réquisitionnés pour accueillir ces
réfugiés on ne savait ni les lieux de
ces sites ni la date à laquelle allait
être accueillis ces réfugiés et même le
jour même de leur arrivée notre
journaliste qui était sur place
une arrivée qui était prévu le matin et
finalement ils ne sont arrivés que
l'après midi c'est vrai qu'il ya eu très
peu d'informations très peu de transport
association en charge de tout ça n'avait
pas spécialement le droite communiqué
envoyé par la préfecture qui elle ne
souhaitait pas communiquer voilà donc
c'était très difficile de savoir à
pression ça c'est négocier notre journée
ça avait pu aller plutôt ça peut
s'expliquer parce attend mais aussi
d'informer la population et de rassurer
aussi parce que chacun on dit je veux je
ne veux pas chez moi mais si déjà il y
avait un peu plus de transparence un
contexte qui est hostile c'est allé dire
au maire de mantes la ville
on va vous envoyer on va installer une
centaine de réfugiés tibétains entre la
ville met alors en de fous furieux et
ont peu et il est capable d'organiser
une contre-manifestation où une
manifestation contre l'arrivée des
tibétains et je pense que c'est ni
approprié ni le moment et les services
de la préfecture ce que je peux
parfaitement comprendre en tout intérêt
à ce que n'y ait pas lieu ce type
d'événement cyril notre cas réagi via
son compte twitter et la mer devant ta
vie il faut qu il réagi
dans lequel il déclarait cette décision
tant sur la forme que sur le fond sera
contestée par toutes voies de recours
possibles
c'est quand même le maire qui depuis sur
les trois dernières années n'a jamais
réuni son conseil municipal avec le
quorum en faiseur la vivre juste après
fait la trêve avec le maroc manque la
ville jeu qui n'est pas là pour vous
répondre
le maire d'achères lui on a pensé quoi
alors le maire d'achères effectivement
on n'a pas pu joindre syrie le nôtre
puisque ses complices communication d
indiquer que le maire de mantes la ville
n'ajouterait rien la suite à son tweet
mais par contre le maire d'achères par
contre rappelait quant à lui le contexte
de vie ou plutôt de survie de ces de ces
réfugiés à l'antenne de mfm et surtout
les raisons pour lesquelles ils ont dû
être évacués d'urgence et dans ces
conditions on écoute le maire d'achères
compétition de gier est dignité impact
devant sa fille françoise plus teaser
personnes qui campaient sous des tentes
dans bordeaux 9 saint germain dans le
froid sous la pluie sur l'hygiène à part
toi robinet qu'on avait mis nous la
mairie d'achères des conditions
inacceptables pour des faits des gens
dans cette situation là bien longtemps
un futur qui est des petits van ly oui
qu'ils soient suivis par une association
sous la serre où la route et après vous
être regroupés dans 50 ou 60 pour alain
prononcées ont fait un recensement des
bâtiments disponibles qui était
susceptible mais il ya des types et 1 50
ou 100 ou 200 pendant qu'ils sont
répartis sur cinq
voilà pour cette actualité concernant
les réfugiés tibétains notamment donc
avec ce second démanteler du côté de la
chaire ce mois ci et les tibétains
répartis à travers le département autre
sujet pour ce deuxième numéro du club de
la presse les faits qui nous
l'expression a été popularisé par le
président américain qui aime l'utiliser
à tort et à travers elle est surtout
révélatrice du mauvais côté des réseaux
sociaux du trop plein d'informations
quelquefois du mélange dangereux aussi
entre la communication et l'information
j'insiste sur cette différence là les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines ont lancé un cycle
d'intervention autour du sujet la
programmation est à retrouver sur leur
site i média thèque points à sky point
fr la première a eu lieu le 28 novembre
dernier reportage avant de parler des
faits qui nous en plateau les fake news
qui signifie fausses informations sont
entrés dans
entre langage courant pour lutter contre
la désinformation une conférence était
organisée à la médiathèque du canal sur
le thème du climat
on n'a pas un journal
délaissant des chiffres qui sont
produits ou qui sont contestés par la
suite donc ça nous a semblé intéressant
pour une médiathèque de traiter ces
sujets là pierre hippolyte senlis a
animé cette conférence et fait partie de
l'association fait coffre première
association de journalistes à s'engager
contre la désinformation de masse avec
trente journalistes ils se sont
regroupés suite aux attentats de charlie
hebdo mais on avait un peu tout les
toutes les théories
complotistes ou de désinformation un peu
con qui sont sortis donc ça est un peu
violent et là on sait on s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire la défiance
médiatique a été abordé avec les 50
participants avec tchernobyl l'incendié
lui brille seul et de rouen ils ont
aiguisé leur esprit critique
ils sont revenus également sur greta
tanberg la lanceuse d'alert le
journaliste à alerter le public sur
l'importance de vérifier les sources
un premier pas pour lutter contre la
désinformation pas ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé et que je ne connaissais pas
c'est la recherche inverse sur
d'une information on aime photo pixum
google en inverse et nous dit cette
photo elle date de talent époque se
rapprocher de l'essentiel c'est le
message du journaliste lors de cette
conférence
la prochaine aura lieu le jeudi 7
janvier à 19 heures à la médiathèque du
canal quelle approche avez vous les uns
des autres dans vos médias de ces faits
qui news alors la règle de base d'un
journaliste est vérifié cette
information de trois fois avant de la
publier c'est la règle de base sont deux
verbes et retard de la jourre vérifier
vérifier si vous attaquez faut avoir la
preuve sur la table on a été éduqué
aujourd'hui c'est moins le cas voilà
même si les rédacteurs en chef fathi
banques sur la table mais c'est un petit
peu moins le cas aujourd'hui mais c'est
la faute aussi à la demande des des
zones leader des téléspectateurs il faut
aller vite il faut avoir l'information
c'est l'information en continu votre
approche les uns des autres des faits
qui nous est ce que vous y êtes
confrontés en presse locale non pas plus
que ça puisque on a on a une proximité
avec les faits qui fait que
on est on peut commettre des erreurs
mais jamais des fêtes news donc en
presse locale c'est pas un souci là où
yahoo il ya un vrai problème aujourd'hui
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux c'est sur
internet puisqu'il faut se le dire aussi
vous avez des états notamment la russie
mais pas seulement la russie qui
développe des fêtes news pour influencer
des populations d'autres pays où la vue
sur l'élection américaine de donald
trump l'effet que news ont fortement
contribué à l'élection de donald trump
donc oui sur turin niveau national voire
international lui l'effet que nous on
une vraie puissance sur deux du local
très peu il ya la proximité je pense que
yossi - d'immédiateté en local
on ad on a des journaux télévisés tous
les jours mais on n'est pas dans
l'information en continu comme sur
certains médias nationaux des chaînes
voilà pourquoi les cités hlm celle de la
mairie fille katia le temps la
vérification tout à fait même si sur
certains événements moi je pense aux
attentats du 13 novembre alors j'étais
pas encore arrivé à kiev et 78 mais des
informations sur les réseaux sociaux je
me rappelle d'une information in famous
qui avaient circulé sur le péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines où on avait
parlé d'une voiture avec un commando
armé à bord qui avait débarqué après
vérification en fait donc il ya des
médias chinois qui avaient partagé cette
information et après vérification en
fait il s'avérait que c'était juste une
voiture qui avait dévié de sa
trajectoire dernier moment au péage de
saint-arnoult et savez c'est le tweet en
valeur des avec un tweet d'un
journaliste inquiéter partie d'un
journaliste alors pas yvelinois main
journalistes de presse nationale qui
avait effectivement semer semer le
trouble
voilà c'est simple c'est encore la
proximité quand on écrit sur des choses
qui se passent à quelques kilomètres on
fait attention
ce qu'on sait que les gens vont venir
vous souhaitez donc oui on va les
croisés effectivement le retour de bâton
est immédiat est-ce qu'on veut le
gouvernement de pékin il viendra
prochainement leur actif il a craint la
perte de crédibilité s'il me souffler
les gens vous la dire aussi matin il ya
les délits deep news tu as vu les
distilleurs les avec les vidéos par on
va recruter ont leurs propres outils
nous lui fait dire n'importe quoi
maintenant des confronté à ça c'est
tellement bien fait la technique va
tellement loin ont magnifié aujourd'hui
les images on n'est pas possible on
n'est pas sûr que c'est lui c'est
vraiment compliqué mais en tout cas il
ya une certaine éducation du public qui
se fait aussi de plus en plus de
demandes de vérification de cette
information même sur les sujets les plus
anodins je voudrais revenir sur ce sujet
parce qu'il a concerné indirectement le
département même directement le
département des yvelines
l'exemple et on en revient aux grèves de
ce salarié qui parcourt tous les matins
tous les jours 30 km à pied on le voit
sur ces images
alain fonteneau qui qui fait le trajet
entre la verrière et paris 30 km
on l'a traité a notamment grégory cgt on
l'a rencontré au moment de la du décès
d'agnès varda puisqu'il est il y avait
il est apparu dans le documentaire
d'agnès varda le les glaneurs et la
glaneuse alors pour vous donner le fond
de cette histoire bfm a consacré un
reportage à cette personne le journal 20
minutes nous a contactés en faisant une
recherche parce qu'ils voulaient
vérifier si l'information était vraie
est ce qu il faisait vraiment 30 km
comme nous avions déjà réalisé un
reportage
nous avons mis en relation et donc il ya
eu tout un fact checking et même un
autre journal national encore à refaire
un fact checking du fact checking donc
les médias en sont à se vérifier leurs
informations les uns et les uns entre
entre les autres c'est un petit petit
clin d'oeil sur cette histoire histoire
là et puis tout de même il ya cette
information des faits qui nous inquiète
prise assez au sérieux le csa qui a
confié avec qui avec cette nouvelle loi
pardon ont-ils fait que nous a décidé de
mettre en place depuis fin 2010 8
veiller à l'application des règles
imposées aux plateformes en ligne
notamment voilà le csa qui impose des
règles plus dures en plus strictes et
qui veut que les journalistes s'attelle
il ya même des commissions qui vont
surveiller
est ce que nous faisons les uns et les
autres à l'ascension mais si on a le
temps juste un mot du côté de la femme
radio sur les ateliers radio parce que
là l'éducation aux médias et la
responsabilité qu'on a en tant que média
est doublé on a mené une petite
expérience j'organisais des ateliers
radio effectivement cela absolument et
docks ou un item éducation humide et aux
médias et intégrée alors on leur à leur
a soumis des faits qui nous l'effet news
les plus populaires sur un échantillon
de dix jeunes
si ça vous intéresse l'invs leur a posé
on leur a soumis des fake va pouvoir 6 y
adhérer ou pas et les vaccins sont
mauvais pour la santé par exemple ça
emporté 20 % d'adhésion donc même chez
les jeunes vous voyez c'est déjà déjà
très installé le 11 septembre est un
complot organisé par les usa attention
c'est 50% sur un échantillon de 10 de 10
jeunes et attention bonus l'homme n'a
jamais marché sur la lune 70%
donc autant vous dire qu'il ya du
travail
les médias mais je pense effectivement
qu'il ya aussi un enjeu fort sur
l'éducation qu'on peut avoir sur les
faits que news parce que des fois
défectueuse qui circulent on on se
demande comment elles peuvent circuler
juste avec quelques réflexes quelques
vérifications on peut on peut trouver
tout de suite qu'il s'agit d'une
technique donc je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu fort sur l'éducation pour conclure
ce billet une maison oui en fait partie
mais pour conclure ce tour d'horizon des
actualités du moi parlons aussi des
municipales vous allez constater dans
les prochaines semaines multiplication
des listes sans étiquette citoyenne
participative elles ont toujours existé
ces candidates candidats qui ce qui ne
se réclame d'aucun parti seulement cette
fois-ci même ceux qui font partie d'un
parti politique préfère la cacher cette
étiquette un mouchoir dessus on oublie
au niveau national on peut pas dire par
exemple qu'anne hidalgo met en avant
beaucoup son label parti socialiste et
pourtant on pourrait aussi citer le vice
président du rassemblement national où
ils frites juste une précision là dessus
et qu'elle n'est pas encore candidate
officiellement elle n'est pas encore
candidat mais on la candidate
l'autre exemple que je voulais donner va
vous plaire le vice président du
rassemblement national qui lui dit mener
une liste apolitique sur perpignan
voilà est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
qu'on est face à une évolution de la
politique ou plutôt d'une volonté
quelquefois dissimulation des
dissimulations un peu de son étiquette
aller la bible forcément voilà je sais
je sais que le sujet va vous intéresser
mais enfin c'est un peu logique fin il
ya plus de droite la gauche a été
explosée quoi qu'elle est en train de se
reconstruire la droite et les en face
d'eux d'explosion
arts visuels ce qui fait que en réalité
les maires vont sur leur propre personne
et sur l'élection prochaine
on s'en fout des étiquettes les gens ne
voteront pas en fonction d'une étiquette
ils voteront en fonction d'un homme ou
d'une femme
et en l'occurrence ils ont tout intérêt
à ne pas mettre une étiquette parce que
ça repousse au jour d'une éthique c'est
pour ça qu'à quelques semaines tout le
monde se battait pour avoir
l'investiture en marche aujourd'hui plus
personne se bat pour la semaine on veut
des fois des soutiens mais pas plus et
comme lorsque les investitures ou le
soutien arrive les candidats disent non
mais moi j'ai rien demandé je ne veux
pas c'est gentil me soutiennent voilà et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya une très forte
prime aux sortants vers les gens vont
surtout se référer au maire en place ou
la met en place une volonté décoller les
étiquettes et puis puis la stratégie
aussi il faut le dire l'objectif c'est
de rassembler large les les étiquettes
face à la déliquescence des partis on a
plutôt plutôt tendance à capitaliser
comme vous dites autour il ya de la
stratégie s creed
vous soupçonnez pas quelques candidats
peut-être de vouloir avancer masqué si
votre allusion elle est faite sur sur le
maire masséna de mantes la ville se
croient que je crois que le problème est
réglé c'est ceci dit ceci dit il de
nombreux tête de liste nombreuses têtes
de liste que ce soit des républicains de
la gauche aux autres générations ou
autres de gauche ne souhaitent vraiment
pas la mettre cette étiquette en avant
et on est confronté à ce problème
notamment quand est ce qu'on les reçoit
en plateau
on se doit en tant que journaliste ou
même d'informer et de dire aux futurs
électeurs pour qui ils vont voter mais
les candidats préfèrent dire non moi
c'est plutôt divers droite divers gauche
voir que ce qui s'en dit la ressentent
voir qu'elle a faits divers divers tout
court mais ça c'est un processus qui
s'est mis en place j'irais depuis les
élections de présidentielle de 2017 ou
même avant ce temps des municipales nous
on a eu des appels en rédaction vous le
savez de mer qui ne souhaitait plus
qu'on attribue une étiquette socialiste
les républicains et qu'il préférait
avoir une étiquette plutôt divers gauche
divers droite c'est la vie qui est un
petit peu cette règle là normalement les
préfectures au moment du dépôt des
listes sont censés aussi donner des
tendances à divers droite 10
argos sauf que visiblement pour les
communes de moins de 9000 habitants
restent à valider mais ce ne sera plus
le cas maintenant le préfet ne mettra
plus d'étiquette donc sans éthique ce
sera sans étiquette pour tout le monde
c'est plus compliqué comme si malgré
tout ça reste plus compliqué on sait
savoir mais la tendance même si sur la
personne voilà je veux dire qu'on vient
un peu les politiques liées au thème
logiquement c'est gestion de la ville
revient donc à la base c'est de gérer la
ville et enfin j'ai des exemples de
communes
si le me lemaire est de gauche mais qui
travaille bien et qu'il est là mais même
des gens de droit de voter pour lui et
vice versa c'est un maire de droite fait
un bon boulot qu'ils augmenteront les
impôts les des gens de gauche ont voté
pour lui parce que c'est un bon maire on
sait qu'il est la personnalité politique
préférée à chaque fois des citoyens il
ya deux phénomènes plus que ces mères
qui veulent se détacher des étiquettes
politiques politique des élus en général
je pense qu'aussi une volonté des
habitants dans un deuxième temps de
s'engager politiquement et de fleurir
ces démarches citoyennes avec des gens
impliqués dans l'associatif locales dans
les commerces locaux qui se lancent qui
n'ont pas eu de mandat d'élu dans voilà
dans des conseils municipaux et qui se
lancent dans cette bataille des
municipales en même temps
si on regarde bien vous n'avez pas
autant de listes que ça partout dans
toutes les villes en tout cas ce qui
s'annonce aujourd'hui c'est moins de
lisbonne en amont via sa régie sont
globalement dix candidates sur les
communes c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
semble en tout cas il faudra attendre le
28 février date de dépôt des listes pour
le vérifier mais en préfecture mais
c'est vrai que mes seins sont en
conséquence logique du fait qu'il n'ait
plus de parti alors que c'est des
individus qui portent des listes et du
coup c'est plus compliqué mais c'est pas
surprenant ce que je dirai à ça c'est
que c'est absolument pas surprenant dans
le contexte politique national qu'on est
con et les conséquences de peu de listes
en local puisque et puis en même temps
ça fait assez en même temps que je vais
finir par l'adopter on est et en même
temps il ya plus de gauche la plus
droite et du temps en plus sur ses
étiquettes effectivement sur les listes
citoyenne c'est le cas pas de volonté de
mettre en avant forcément une tête de
liste de mettre en avant plusieurs
personnes puisque c'est l'eau et porte
un projet de plusieurs personnages
c'est tout à fait on referme cette
parenthèse dédiée à l'actualité du mans
paso personnalité du mois à présent dans
le club de la presse
[Musique]
le club de la presse sur tv 78è les
faits mais également les personnalités
yvelinoise du mois alors de manière tout
à fait subjectif bien évidemment pour
vous permettre de lattre il s'agit de
gérard larcher sénateur des yvelines
président du sénat et sénateur sur le
secteur de rambouillet oui donc gérard
seguin de sortir un livre qui s'appelle
le contre-pouvoir face à monsieur macro
donc larcher s'est quand même je vous
parlais de mantes la ville
non j'étais journaliste prendra plus de
40 ans au niveau politique que moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour eux alors c'est
parce que c'est un bosseur sa griffe est
du terrain du terrain c'est sa force
quoi ibos regardez comment il a pris
sénat il a battu deux fois raffarin
paradait devant les télés tout lui il
est du terrain il a fait le tour de la
france dans toutes les communes et qui a
gagné ce larcher deux fois il a battu
rafa est à rambouillet mais tout le
monde le connaît il se balade dans la
rue de dans la rue de gaulle de
rambouillet alors il connaît tout le
monde parle et n'ont pratiquement alors
le fils savent astuce il vous invite pas
avoir un impôt quoi donc
ces colliers c'est la personnalité
politique qui défend le plus les mères
justement c'est ça il y à là d'une
petite ville de normandie il est vain
terminèrent il a été entraîneur l'équipe
de france d'équitation 1976 quand il
était champion olympique il était il est
vétérinaire des leçons de la fac de
de lyon comme une grande école
vétérinaire et c'est un gars qui est
vraiment du terrain un gars de la
campagne ou collège il était en internat
donc il a été pilier de rugby sanguin
quel sens du sport du travail 10 km ou
vieux maillot c'est lui qui regardent
l'opposition aujourd'hui le plus banal
on était à la séance de dédicaces à la
médiathèque de rambouillet effectivement
bon on comprend clairement ses positions
alors déjà il ya un constat qui est qui
ressort dans cet ouvrage je sens que mon
pays ne va pas bien donc les mêmes
phrases qui pose un petit peu le le
cadre est alors on lui a posé la
question de ses relations avec emmanuel
macron et on ne peut combler a surtout
demandé comment telle approche politique
d' emmanuel macron il a répondu sans
équivoque
laverty la verticalité mène à l'impasse
voilà donc du coup l'opposition pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'opposition
je veux dire quand il était ministre du
travail pôle haut de trois ans et c'est
là où il ya eu les meilleurs résultats
le chômage a baissé il n'y a pas eu de
grandes grèves et là dans les gens qui
disent des hommages de gérard larcher il
ya laurent berger secrétaire général de
la cgt qui dit comme c'est facile de
dialoguer avec gérard larcher et de le
joindre le câble de besoin vous êtes
aussi en campagne de la numéro deux de
la france et métaux monsieur la crau et
un pépin de santé et tout de suite il
recevrait les syndicats et il ya eu le
congrès national de force ouvrière à
rambouillet tout s'est bien passé
il est très respecté par les
syndicalistes parce qu'il respecte les
syndicats il est conçu qui les écoutent
longuement et ça change pas mal la donne
et c'est un gars de terrain quel sens du
peuple
un peu comme de gaulle de gaulle avait
vu le sacrifice du peuple français dans
les tranchées le paysan l'ouvrier
lessard hate boys qui sont prêts à
défendre le pays est l'archi là le même
ce respect du peuple pour lui chaque
français ne vous arrête plus vous
arrêter général
inter la radio qui déconsidère le genre
du peu monsieur larcher a le sens du
pôle ça c'est pour ça qu'il est là
dedans brièvement il a quitté la
politique et les demeures de l'état il
n'est pas du parti du président à qui il
a une position législatif qui lui qui
lui impose quelque part d'être le
premier opposant mais en dehors de ça
bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui ce qui
ressort de noeuds de gérard larcher mais
globalement de cette ancienne génération
d'hommes de droite qui sont des hommes
de terrain ce qu'on a plus aujourd'hui
les gens de droite mais globalement ce
sont surtout des gens de droite plateaux
télé alors que des gérard larcher aide
jacques chirac en son temps était limal
ces sons des chants proche du terrain
des gens qui disent bonjour à tous qui
connaisent ce soulèvement leur
territoire et les habitants de ce
territoire sur le bout des doigts qui me
laisser sans la plus connaissent surtout
la laisse pas les faveurs
on déshabille nous pouvons rêver 70
c'est vrai que s'ils seront ainsi
disponibles autour des décennies perdues
on quitte la politique hs j'ai pas je
saurai déjà pour la personnalité du mois
en ce qui concerne tv 78 la sélection le
capitaine n'a rien à voir c'est une
ventriloque
elle est accompagnée à d'elliot son
dragon pour nous oui vous allez voir les
images elle vient du cinéroc en course
et notre personnalité et à la gagne et
elle a gagné l'émission de m6 la france
a un incroyable talent et ceci dit très
sérieusement ça c'est rare d'avoir des
femmes ventre et l'on regarde un petit
effet et qui sait pas quoi
j'ai une nouvelle passion ah ouais je ne
nouveaux talents sanair y être hostiles
et c'est quoi le beat box
c'est quoi ça le beatbox montre regarde
c'est là qu'un seul carnet ce truc je te
jure regarde même l'abîmé bluffé a gagné
la france a un incroyable talent sur m6
elle a découvert son temps et 14 ans
aujourd'hui elle a 20 ans et je peux
vous dire que pour tenter de réaliser un
reportage avec elle c'est assez
compliqué parce qu'elle est en tournée à
travers toute la france depuis sa
victoire et son passage sur l'émission
de m6
votre personnalité à présent hakima
francois marne a absolument françois
marin la meslée plus connu dans le monde
de la danse sous le nom de francs quoi
c'est un jeune homme originaire du
quartier du val fourré il a 28 ans et il
a été il a remporté le titre de champion
du monde 2019 de house dance il était
d'ailleurs honoré ce mois ci par la
ville de mantes la jolie pour ses
victoires puisque c'est la deuxième il y
avait déjà remporté le juste debout et
puis aussi pour son nom son engagement
auprès des jeunes à travers son
association start to step c'est notre
personnalité du moins pour plusieurs
raisons déjà c'est un ambassadeur des
cultures urbaines et de la culture hip
hop est une culture qui est très
présente sur les ondes de mfm radio
et c'est aussi et surtout un exemple de
réussite et bénéficie de l'image de deux
grands frères 1 par tous et même au delà
du monde de la danse d'ailleurs on
écoute tous sont dans le quartier que ce
soit mon avis que ce soit
à l'étranger enfin c'est là qu'on
réalise yeux on a quand même fait un
exploit puisque aujourd'hui je pensais
même pas aller jusqu'au bout c'est un
parcours du combattant
vraiment on n'était qu'à 250 entre 450
et 500 participants pourront finalement
gardé qu'un se dire que c'est soi même
alors que on a les précurseurs de cette
branche qui participent aussi des
japonais et des américains qui est finir
premier honnêtement c'est c'est énorme
saguenay d'humanité de marnach nous
avions reçu notamment sur tv 60,18 c'est
votre personnalité pour un effet mais
nous l'avons reçu et 7,7 aura deux
grands frères personnage très
sympathique mais dégager aussi sur notre
plateau mais ces mois-ci cinquième
édition du mary mary crise menthe qui co
organise aussi nous la personnalité du
mois sur le mois de décembre
vous y serez peut-être la bible vous
habitez le guépard blanc c'est votre
personnalité la vie politique qui est un
genre un parcours qui t'a l'envoyant
d'ailleurs un parcours très atypique
puisqu'il a commencé
il est natif de versailles il a voulu
faire du basket ce n'était pas possible
il a essayé le judo mais le club de
guyancourt n'a pas mis les moyens pour
qu'ils puissent
pratiquer ce sport et s'est retourné
s'est tourné vers l'athlétisme et il est
vice champion du monde du 100 m champion
du monde du 400 m avec un temps quand
même extrêmement intéressant sur le 100
m puisqu'on est sur mon second de 0,9
et ouais pour moi c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui mérite d'être connu et
puis c'est aussi mettre mettre de la
lumière sur l'an 10 sport qui ça touche
énormément de gens dans notre société et
je pense que les failles il va tokyo
l'année prochaine mais je pense qu'on
met pas suffisamment lumière seat est là
qui sont qui ont de vous à moi qui sont
encore bien plus performant que des
athlètes valides
parce que eux partent avec un handicap
aurait fondé tant qu'ils sont
extrêmement extrêmement fort et
quelquefois rivalisent avec les arcs les
athlètes valides aussi un quelquefois et
on espère qu'il y aura un coup de
projecteur qui sera donné avec les jeux
olympiques en france en 2024 puisque
notamment on est sur le territoire
yvelinois voilà territoire yvelinois
accueille plusieurs plusieurs épreuves
pour 2024 et pour les jeux olympiques
mais aussi les jeux paralympiques qui
fait de la musique aussi
ira pas si vous êtes au courant bien
vite sera peut-être sur l fm vous pour
découvrir cet univers là bientôt à la
une sur les différentes éditions de la
gazette de elles fm de tv 78 c'est notre
dernière séquence
bientôt la fin de ce club de la presse
diffusée sur tv 78 sur l fm
participation également ce mois ci de la
gazette et puis d'un auteur ancien
journaliste à toutes les nouvelles
pendant de nombreuses années
bernard delattre grégory sur tv 78 à
l'honneur un l'honneur jeu prochainement
donc c'est une actualité qui va arriver
en janvier c'est le lancement officiel
de l'université paris saclay cette méga
universités qui va regrouper à terme 70
d'étudiants dix mille enseignants
chercheurs qui nous concerne directement
puisque lé sur le plateau de saclay qui
est un territoire tout proche mais aussi
parce que l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
d'abord occupé cette université dans un
statut d'université membres avant de
fusionner totalement en 2025 alors
l'objectif de cette université c de
concurrencer les grands standards
mondiaux de vol à progresser dans les
classements internationaux
il y aura aussi un intérêt à suivre
cette actualité
il sera intéressant de voir comment va
se comporter l'université face un autre
groupe d'écoles qui s'est monté aussi
sur le plateau de saclay autour de
l'école polytechnique qui rassemble
notamment hec le est à paris paristech
et il sera intéressant de voir comment
va se comporter
la grosse université paris saclay avec
ce pôle est ce que on sera dans une
stratégie de collaboration ou voilà de
grandir de concurrence pure et dure ce
sera intéressant de voir l'université de
versailles saint quentin qui rejoint
paris saclay mais il faut pas oublier
que l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines est présente sur
l'intégralité du département des
yvelines ne peut pas faire plus exploser
comme universités aux quatre coins du
département on retrouve des des entités
donc bientôt ce sera une seule et même
université paris saclay hakima je me
tourne vers vous pour découvrir le sujet
qui sera bientôt à la une des bus 2020
pourra les faits mais va en parlera des
dalles enfants c'est aussi de lutte
contre la maltraitance infantile à
l'aune des trente ans la convention
internationale et des enfants qu'on fera
un focus sur les moyens a mis en place
sur le territoire pour la protection des
enfants dans le cadre de la refonte de
la politique d' aide à l'enfance du
territoire ça sera retrouvé un dossier a
retrouvé début 2020 et pour les gazettes
c'est la bible alors sur exit de saint
quentin va parler de la piscine
qui va ouvrir en 2020 maurepas qui est
une partenariat entre la ville
d'elancourt 2022 2024 du chantier ne
donnait pas de faux espoirs aux
habitants qu'ils attendent depuis des
années je payais qui est passé au
conseil aux deux conseils municipaux de
mortal repas et d'elancourt mardi
dernier sur sur la gazette en yvelines
en fait je ne sais pas si vous recevez
voulait le fil des infos sur le
département mais mais globalement il ya
énormément énormément de femmes battues
de d'hommes qui sont mis à arrêter et
c'est pour des faits de violence envers
les femmes et on va faire un gros
dossier parce que c'est ça nous a un peu
frappé sur le sujet ça c'est quasiment
tous les jours
2/3 de trois sujets qui nous arrivent
par le fils sont du fait divers d'une
façon générale ce sont les faits divers
on le constate alors là on change
complètement sujet mais effectivement
dans les faits divers montés générale de
la violence liée à un nouveau bout
différents mouvements de contestation
aussi un qui sont exprimés on peut
reparler des gilet jaune on parle de la
manifestation des mobilisations
actuelles
mais effectivement cette grogne est
colère se traduit aussi en violences
puis le mois dernier nous parlons aussi
de ce qui est survenu du côté de
chanteloup les violences aussi dans
certaines des communes effet fillon mais
on arrive à proximité de la saint
sylvestre donc évidemment qu'on a qu'on
va avoir des retombées sur le sujet j'en
profite petites questions annexes c'est
toujours la grande question qui se pose
aussi dans les médias sur le traitement
de la saint sylvestre et des éventuels
parlons débordement est ce que vous
communiquez vous donner les chiffres
vous informer sur les chiffres dans vos
rédactions respectives
parce qu'il ya toujours ce jeudi là on
ne donne pas les chiffres on préfère pas
les données parce que ça serait rentré
dans le jeu justement entre les
quartiers les à celui qui aura à brûler
le plus de voitures pour faire simple
nous on ne le fait pas tous hein parce
que quand on rentre dans un
là ça devient un jeu wii est hélas quand
on nous impose d'être partenaire de ce
jeu à travers une information veux pas
rentrer dans ce jeu-là y du coup
on ne communique pas sur le chiffre que
soient ceux qui travaillent la sortie
l'ouest voilà le boulanger des
restaurants l'hôpital puis aussi on
faisait le premier bébé de l'année et le
dernier bébé quoi ce les services
d'urgences sociales qui sont très actifs
forcément c'est durant ses dires est
question aussi de la deûle équilibre si
on est quand même dans une période
d'avant fait un petit peu particulière
je pense que tous les rédacteurs en
chefs doivent se poser la même question
à savoir bon là on a quand même une
actualité qui est très dur violent quand
on rassemble tous à un moment on a
toujours les marronniers et puis les
côtes de le côté un petit peu fun
économie qui tourne la foire le marché
l'ice beaucoup moins le cas puisque déjà
l'économie est au ralenti les transports
sont alors si on ajoute en plus toute la
violence qui s'ajoute
bon ça fait ça finit pas d'être à sion
et c'est vrai que la question se pose et
s'est posé en transparence donc je
comprends je valide le cadre du fer est
super derrière une transition de comme
résiste pour terminer cette édition du
club de la presse j'aimerais vous
montrer les unes aussi de toutes les
nouvelles pour cette fin d'année pour
l'édition de versailles-saint-quentin
retour sur les 26 caméras piétons
distribuer aux pompiers du département
pour endiguer les phénomènes de violence
voilà on y revient encore une fois et
puis on les y sion rambouillet chevreuse
d'autres caméras à l'honneur avec un
focus sur le dispositif de
vidéoprotection voilà on y est aussi sur
ces problématiques là qui sont réels et
qui peuvent inquiéter forcément les
différents concitoyens merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce numéro du
club de la presse dans les yvelines
hakima ya pour l fm radio bernard
delattre ancien journaliste toutes les
nouvelles lahbib eddaouidi directeur des
gazettes et puis grégory canal est aussi
rédacteur en chef adjoint de tv 78 on se
retrouve
j'ai dit adjoint de cette fois ci la
question s'est posée tout à l'heure à
mon nom grégory je n'ai pas de cadeaux
vous faire pour la fin d'année
je serai bien là alors entré aussi merci
à vous quatre et très bonne fête bien
sûr on se retrouve au mois de janvier
merci encore
[Musique]